منذ بدايه الحرب في غزه تصاعدت الهجمات
على القوات الامريكيه في المنطقه حيث قالت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان قواتها تعرضت
في العراق وسوريا الى
151 هجوما منذ اكتوبر الماضي الهجوم
الاخير اذا وفقا للروايه الامريكيه استهدف
بطائره مسيره قاعده البرج 22 حيث تتمركز
قوات امريكيه شمال شرقي الاردن قرب الحدود
مع سوريا قبل ذلك استهدفت المقاومه
الاسلاميه في العراق موا قع تمركز للقوات
الامريكيه في سوريا ابرزها الهجوم على
قاعده كونيكو والقاعده الامريكيه في حقل
العمر والشدادي وقاعده رميلان والقاعده
الامريكيه في مطار خراب الجير بمحافظه
الحسكه في العراق تعرض كل من مطار اربيل
وقاعده عين الاسد لهجمات استهدفت قوات
امريكيه ننوه مشاهدينا ايضا ب هذا الخبر
العاجل دائما ضمن البيان الصادر عن
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه تقول بانه تم
اجلاء ثمانيه من الجنود الجرحى من الاردن
للحصول على رعايه صحيه متقدمه وتقول ايضا
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه بان الهجوم وقع
على قاعده الدعم اللوجستي عند البرج 22 من
شبكه الدفاعات
الاردنيه للمتابعه ينضم الينا من نيويورك
محمد سطوحي الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشان
الامريكي مرحبا بك معنا اذا باتت القوات
الامريكيه في مرمى
الاستهداف ذكرت عددا كبيرا حوالي 150 منذ
عمليه طوفان الاقصى ها وقد ادى ذلك
الاستهداف الى مقتل ثلاثه امريكيين وجرح
اربعه
هل في تقديرك الولايات المتحده ستغير من
استراتيجيتها في الشرق الاوسط دعمها لا
محدود لاسرائيل الذي بحسب الجهات التي
هاجمت هو سبب
فعلتها هو بدايه احيانا تحقق الهجمات
نجاحا ربما اكثر مما يتمناه من شن هذه
الهجمات واعتقد ان هذا
نموذج مثل هذا ربما يكون غير مطلوب
بالنسبه لمن يقوم به الجانب الامريكي طوال
الاشهر القليله الاخيره كانت هناك تلك
الهجمات الكثيره التي تعرضت لها قواته
وقواعده العسكريه في المنطقه لكن كانت
دائما هجمات لا تتسبب في مقتل جنود
امريكيين واصابات طفيفه بينهم فكانت تمر
بشكل يكفي فيه للاداره الامريكيه ان تشن
هجمات بسيطه متقطعه تقوم من خلالها بارسال
فقط رسائل الى ايران والقوات المؤيده لها
او التي تدعمها في المنطقه هذه المره وقعت
الواقعه هناك جنود امريكيون قتلوا بالفعل
في هجمه اخيره ومن هنا انا اتصور انه
اداره بايدن سيكون محتما عليها وخصوصا وهي
في هذه السنه الانتخابيه ان تقوم بهجوم
مضاد قوي لانه الرئيس الامريكي لن يسمح
بان يبدو كما لو كان رجل
ضعيفا في البيت الابيض وانه دونالد ترامب
لن يتركه دون ان يشن عليه هجمات كثيره
بانه الرئيس الذي سمح بمقتل الجنود
الامريكيين وانه لو كان رئيسا ما كان ذلك
قد حدث و بالتالي الرئيس بايدن سيحاول ان
يرسل رساله ليس فقط للخارج ليس فقط لايران
او القوات التي تدعمها ولكن ايضا للداخل
بانه رئيس قوي يدافع عن القوات الام
امريكيه ويرد الصع صعين عندما يتعرضون
لمثل هذه الجمات اذا تذهب الى رايي بان
هذه الاستراتيجيه والدعم الاسرائيل لن
يتغير في المقابل ستلج الولايات المتحده
للرد مباشره على من استهدفهم او على من
تقول بانه يدعمهم في
تقديرك ايه هو الرئيس بايدن اشار الى انه
هذه القوات مدعومه من ايران لكنه لم يصل
الى درجه اتهام ايران مباشره انها
المسؤوله عن هذه الجمات لانه واشنطن تعلم
ايضا انه ايران لا تدير عمليات هذه القوات
والكتائب المتنوعه في المنطقه صحيح هناك
دعم هناك علاقات لكنها تتخذ قراراتها
بنفسها في كثير من الاحيان
فبالتالي انا اعتقادي انه سيكون مترددا في
شن حرب مواجهه مباشره مع ايران لان هذا ما
لا يريده خاصه في هذا التوقيت لكن هل هذا
يغير من سياسته تجاه اسرائيل انا اعتقادي
انه هو بالفعل السياسه تغيرت على مدى
الاسابيع الاخيره هو كان يحاول انه يصل
الى حل يسمح بوقف لاطلاق النار حتى ولو
مؤقت لانه يعلم ان استمرار هذه الحرب
بالصوره التي تتم بها لم يعد يخدم المصالح
الامريكيه وانه قد يؤدي الى تصعيد وهو ما
حدث بالفعل وكان يخشى منه الكثيرون في
الولايات المتحده فبالتالي هو لن يغير من
دعم لاسرائيل ولكن في اعتقاد ان سيزداد
ضغطه على الجانب الاسرائيلي للوصول الى حل
ما يسمح بوقف لاطلاق النار بصوره حتى لو
تمت تسميته بانها وقف مؤقت لاطلاق النار
لكنه سيسعى للحصول عليه ثم ربما يحاول مده
فيما بعد
الاردن صرح
فيه مسؤول لرويترز يقول بان الاردن طلب من
الولايات المتحده خلال المده الاخيره
تزويده بالمعدات
يقاف تهديدات من هذا القبيل ولم يلقى ردا
حتى هذه اللحظات هل في تقديرك
بان الولايات المتحده القياده الوسطى
تتحمل مسؤوليه ما باعتبار بانها لم توفر
الحمايه اللازمه لافرادها والحديث هنا عن
350 من الجنود الامريكيين في تلك
القاعده طبعا هي ستتعرض للانتقادات ولكن
ليس لانها لم تقدم هذه الاسلحه للاردن
لانها في كثير من الاحيان تعتمد على نفسها
على القوات الامريكيه نفسها في الدفاع عن
نفسها لانه هناك حامله طائرات في المنطقه
هناك قوات تم ارسالها خصيصا بعد بدء
المعارك في غزه من اجل هذا الهدف تحديدا
وهو حمايه والقواعد والقوات الامريكيه في
المنطقه وتم ارسال صواريخ باتريوت التي من
الممكن ان تواجه اي قذائف او صواريخ موجهه
الى تلك القواعد اذا تمت هناك بالفعل
امدادات كثيره الى القواعد العسكريه في
المنطقه لحمايتها المشكله هي انه مع حجم
الهجمات وتنوع الجهات التي تقوم بتوجيه
هذه الهجمات يصعب ان تسقط كل الصواريخ
الموجهه الى تلك القواعد وكان معلوم تماما
انه احيانا سيكون هناك يوم سيء وتقع فيه
الواقعه هذا ما حدث في هذه الحاله وهو ما
كان ربما غير يعني لا اقول متوقع ولكن على
الاقل كان احتمالا قائما وهو الاحتمال
الذي
ربما يثير التساؤلات الان حول ما يجب على
واشنطن ان تفعله هل هو سحب للقوات
الامريكيه لا اعتقد انه سيتم فورا في كل
الاحوال ولكن ستسعى الى رد ضربه قويه الى
تلك القواعد وهم يدرسون الان الجهات التي
ربما تكون مسؤوله عن توجيه هذه الضربه
ولكن حساب الضربه التي تقوم بها الولايات
المتحده سيكون هو المعضله وهو السؤال
الاكبر بالنسبه لاداره بايدن لانهم يريدون
اولا توجيه ضرب عقابيه لمن قاموا بهذه
الهجمات وفي نفس الوقت الا تكون تصعيديه
تؤدي الى حرب شامله او مواجهه عامه كبيره
مع ايران